but I wanted to tell you a brief story
about the early days of the internet
some of you probably know this I bet you
Tim you will but talk about
misinformation and disinformation they
found that the way to prevent people
from falling for fake news in the early
days of Internet forums was to actually
create more fake news and I wish that
this would get more publicity because it
was talk they wrote about it in Wired
Magazine because people would post when
they would ask questions about how to
you know install their sound card or
modem or whatever put the wrong you're
saying put the wrong the wrong thing
down they would deliberately give the
wrong information they would flood the
boards with disinformation because what
they found was that the more
disinformation the more people adjusted
to to realize I need to be skeptical and
now I know that that I need to check my
information before I do it because I
know that that's out there that's why I
don't believe in Internet censorship
that's why I think Alex Jones should be
on Twitter